to our friends i'll tweet the link and
you can
rebroadcast it if you so desire
i just you know i even did uh
instagram live to promote no way oh okay
awesome
awesome all right i think we are live
let me check on the interwebs
is there anybody out there that can see
us
i've got apparently i don't see it but
we're waiting
let's see here 27 thumbs up
there's one person watching it so far
let's give it a second
sometimes it takes a little while we're
used to instantly
she's very disappointed as well she
should be
i mean she's been a doctor
now we got some people we have some
amazing eyeballs on the prize
welcome everybody to this special live
stream edition of the into the
impossible podcast
with my friend my mentor my advisor
my teacher i don't know my rabbi saying
drinking buddy
dr eric r weinstein how are you today
i am well ish well i've been better
and i've been worse but i'm better now
that you are here
and we have a couple of hundred people
already gathered
around to watch us converse about the
future
the past and the present of
physics of astronomy of cosmology
and of even things like uh this golden
piece of gelt that i've been fixated on
for a long time and we're gonna
get some questions from the audience
because they're complaining
that uh that you have not had a update
on your youtube main channel
with 250 000 subscribers uh people are
getting
they're getting they're getting peeved
let's just say it i quit
did i not foresee this and actually post
a
recent episode of the portal on my
youtube channel brian
behind the time sir oh okay it must have
been like in the last 20 minutes
because i've been checking it hourly um
all right so yes and there is certainly
a portal community and you should check
out eric's channel
portal and you should check out portal
clips he has multiple channels he's gone
he's gone fully hollywood which i salute
and today we're going to talk about
a bunch of uh interviews and a bunch of
new topics that i've been getting into
as we near the end of the real first
season of into the impossible
the podcast that i run here from uc san
diego i've had on many many guests
none as great as as eric of course even
despite all the
all the accolades that some of my guests
have on this got to be
kidding this is the man who's had who
you had recently is sheldon glacier
appeared
i had sheldon glashow that tom tomsky
you're chilling on the guest sir
i'm doing well i'm trying to i'm trying
to bring science communication to the
masses and we're going to have on frank
wilcheck next week
we're going to have on um martin reese
lord
martin reese i'm gonna have to just keep
coming the
astronomer royal is coming on my channel
to tell me
my horoscope as he does with the queen
herself
all right so we're gonna start off with
uh with a conversation
uh between me and eric kind of riffing
on you know we chat
frequently you're very generous with
your time and your space and your space
time
and we're going to talk about a
depression a malady that i had this week
existentially getting to um you know
really
what is this channel about why am i
doing the podcasting that i'm doing
why is it merely a service to do for the
community which i love
and i love scientific outreach and maybe
should it be
an obligation on scientists to
communicate
and i want to hearken back to our first
conversation way back in april
which you can find on my channel in
various places but that was about
the awful terrible no-good job that
physicists
do with the best material on earth
literally on earth in the heavens and we
do a terrible job according to one
dr eric weinstein with publicizing
popularizing and
monetizing what contributions we've made
to humanity what say you sir
i think it's still true i think i
thought first of all you have to realize
that because i'm not
a member of your community but a member
of your viewing public
um i very much uh
appreciate physics from the perspective
of somebody with a bit of a math
background who's been focused on
the reason for learning mathematics for
some of us is theoretical physics
i do think that we we see that the
physics community has some of the
world's most interesting
um product if you want to put it in kind
of crass terms
and there's a huge demand for it because
everyone wants to know
what is this most difficult of fields
what is it telling us about ourselves
uh the purpose of of being
reality itself and yet um there's this
translation issue which i
sort of analogize um
at times to not having an orchestra to
perform
sheet music for people who desperately
want to listen to symphonies
so you keep handing out pages of sheet
music and everybody looks and says wow
that's a lot of squiggly black dots and
lines and a tiny number of people say oh
my god i cried
and you're thinking i wish i could get
there but i have no idea what you're
talking
yeah i often say you know they were
accused of preaching to the choir but
you have to do that when the choir
forgets the melody right
you you cannot ignore it uh and and in
fact
there's no shortage of controversy in
our field i mean just this week
this epic brouhaha erupted with none
other than our friend sabine
haasenfelder hassenfelder dr sabina
hassenfelder
who you debated live with me over the
summer and theories of everything
special podcast
it was brutal um and uh the thriller
in south california i don't know how to
say it but but anyway
the point being that uh she is embroiled
with other
uh titanic intellects including lenny
suskin
so she might call her she picked a fight
with something
she's fearless you know she's like what
five foot two and uh
she she punches you know about uh above
her weight let's just say that
a second got something in my throat
honey badger
badger all right well we can't say that
that is uh forbidden here at the
university of california
we may not refer to it because she's
tenacious and she's
very rarely intimidated that was where i
was going yeah but i
i wanna okay so i'm gonna be the
contrarian today you're gonna be the
optimist
you're gonna be the pollyanna i'm gonna
be the cassandra um
i think a lot of what's happening in in
physics it's become
fashionable to criticize physics to say
nothing good has come out of physics
everything in physics is over hyped that
was her thing this week it was oh the
black hole information lost paradox
which i want to get into because i
talked to lenny about
that this week she calls that the most
over hyped
aspect or topic in all of science
and she's sick of it she says that it's
total nonsense
you can't test it it's irrelevant and
it's by no means the biggest most
important thing
whereas lenny said that he literally the
black hole war
that he waged with stephen hawking in
his book the black hole war
um made the world safe for quantum
mechanics
and the reason he said this is that he
as you know i've been having a lot of
debates lately with people
um like jenna levin even not debates but
she's been on my show i've had on other
people
like lenny like sir roger penrose and i
said
show me the evidence that a singularity
actually exists i know they're beautiful
mathematical objects
i know that they have wonderful
delightful properties
and i said to lenny show me an example
where you know for certain that
singularities exist and then i'll say
it's a problem that we can't unify
gravity with quantum mechanics
and nobody can do that and even roger
when you were you did a guest
appearance on my show with roger
recently and nobody can come up with the
reason that there has to be a
singularity whatsoever
so my claim is do we even need a quantum
theory of gravity sabine is even saying
that's not even as important as or as
unimportant say
as is this issue of the black hole
information loss
problem so just to recap for people that
didn't see the video
lenny claims that the most fundamental
law of nature the so-called negative
first law of thermodynamics
is that information is conserved and
and he claims moreover that the black
hole event horizon
uh or actually to be technical this
thing called that he calls the stretched
horizon
some people call the firewall but that's
even more quantum
than the singularity and but getting
back to my point what if i told you
there is no uh singularity or we'll
never know there's a singularity or not
uh and we don't know if the big bang
actually was a singularity or if it's
like
sir roger postulates or my friend paul
steinhardt postulates that's a cyclic
universe
there is no need for quantum gravity
whatsoever so
shouldn't you get out of the geometric
unity business in other words
why do you think there has to be a
theory of a unified theory of gravity
with um you know just because shelley
did it with with a lecture week
do we have to even have a reason to
think that it's true for gravity plus
the other lighter forces you have opened
up
multiple cans of various sizes of
nematodes sir
and um i don't even know what to say
let's let's just let's just try to
figure out this out for the for the
public yeah see if we can hide our own
ignorance at the same time
uh i guess what i would first start by
saying is that
what's on the line here is that sabine
has become
sort of the curmudgeon to the world
of theoretical physics where you can
sort of reboot in sabine mode rather
than safe mode
and um she will keep you from being
hoodwinked by the various people who
wish to sell you snake oil in the halls
of physics
lenny on the other hand is one of the
architects
of the most dominant and appealing
theory and i would say certainly the
largest
deep program we have whether string
theory is right or wrong
let us not make the mistake of
being
anything less than generous at first
it's an incredibly
generative structure that has produced a
lot a wealth of beautiful mathematics it
may have nothing to do with the physical
world
but it is still richer as a theoretical
and intellectual system
than anything else that is being bandied
about as a potential candidate
so there's a lot on the line when the
most prominent curmudgeon
whether you think she should be or
shouldn't be that's up to you
is speaking to the most prominent
of uh claimants to the founders of the
top
um theoretical framework under
development
what's this really about it's really
about the fact that we're stalled
we should be working on new ideas we
can't quite figure out what to do
so everyone has figured out in some
sense what
he or she is capable of pushing
as a series of pawns across the
chessboard
sabina can can easily say there's no
testable consequences
it's angels on the heads of pins why do
we even need a unified theory maybe it's
not
unified maybe it's not beautiful maybe
maybe maybe maybe
and lenny can say wait a second that's a
lot of
uh that's a lot of emptiness we at least
have done some stuff in string theory
we've predicted gravity
technically postdicted it because we
knew it was there
then he's going to say something about
black holes now i think it's really
important to sort of get
kind of the culture of you guys again
i'm not stepping into this physics ring
but
in a weird way the quintessential
example of a physical system if you had
to learn one
simple physical system and milk it
repeatedly
you say it's a weight on a spring yeah
i can't hear you oh uh oh no
we lost audio contact with dr brown
ground control to brian
keating brian i cannot hear you sir
oh no
there we go how about now i'm not
panicking you replace your aids
going down you hear me now you don't
hear me
three words i hear you you don't hear me
hmm
that's weird dark now you don't hear
anything
all right let's try another thing i do
hear you
you hear me okay so maybe i'll keep
talking and then you keep saying stuff
in in case they reestablished the audio
if not we can always
try back people hear me uh can someone
out there
say that brian i'm gonna open a uh
or find me on it start sending me chats
i hear you um eric let's see
you don't hear me let me uh
let me hold on one second here let me
apologize
brian i wonder if i should hang up you
should keep the stream open and i should
try to log back yeah
see if it's all just change something
let's try that because i don't know if
people can hear me out there
yeah go go for that do that okay yeah do
that
um i believe you can still hear me let
me see
find me on it start sending me chats i
hear
you i hear you and people hear him
so i'm going to try to get eric back on
the line here let me
everybody hears both of us so good okay
apologize
i hear you and let me try to get eric
back
on hold on one second i'm gonna get him
back on
please pardon the interruption but we're
getting more and more people in the chat
room which is good
i tried to switch to a different headset
[Music]
now eric
doctor can you hear me yes i hear you do
you hear me all right i'm gonna try can
you see me
now i see you do you hear me all right
great
so you were saying about sabina as
playing this role
of cassandra so to speak uh but i'm kind
of decrying it that that's become the
fashionable way to go about things
yeah and i i love the fact that you're
giving me an opportunity to be more
optimistic
by pointing out um too much pessimism
right and so i appreciate the
opportunity i don't usually get a chance
to do this a lot has actually happened
in the period that i would say is
generally stagnant
and one of the things that's happened is
is that the foundations of the
mathematics
underneath theoretical physics has
gotten shorn up at an incredible level
one of the reasons i think that we think
that this is going to be more unified
is we find certain motifs permeating
every layer of the physics stack
in particular i would say differential
geometric bundle theory whether it's
the tangent bundle of space-time which
is kind of the default bundle that comes
with the arena in which physics occurs
whether it's
this crazy new bundle called su-3 cross
su-2 cross u1 which
handles the non-gravitational forces
or whether it's what we would call
pre-quantum or quantum line bundles that
live on top of these
structures which give us the
quantization of those classical theories
one of the things that's happened is
that we've gotten
almost all i would say all of
theoretical physics at its most
foundational level now appears to be
differential geometric and differential
topological
now there's a huge question one of the
reasons why i thought that lenny was in
some sense evasive
uh when you tried to ask him about the
singularity it was kind of an
interesting evasion to be honest about
it
but what he said is it doesn't really
matter because we don't see the
singularity the singularity and the
black hole is screen so what we should
really
be looking at is the last thing that we
can probe experimentally which might be
the event horizon or the outside of the
disk
who knows and then the point is now i
don't even have to worry about the
breakdown of the laws of physics and the
challenge to einstein that's happening
inside that
be because if the only things i can test
are outside
that even if physics is happening on the
other side of the event horizon
what what what's it to me
and then you can also go further and say
look maybe the classical stuff that
einstein was up to and all of this
bundle theoretic stuff of simons and
yang you had jim simons on your program
you absolutely have to get xi and yang
and when i get you on rogan you cannot
eat
in front of him because he's got
misophonia i think
and he's very susceptible to sounds like
no one can see me eating with you
but i digress um
i think that you know in in essence
lenny is
uh he's equivocating he doesn't know
what's going on on the other side of
that thing and what i take is
i i'm processing it for meaning i think
that
space-time isn't a crutch to get you to
your quantum theory it's not
you know there's this very fashionable
position which is we shouldn't be
quantizing classical theories we should
be taking the classical limit of quantum
theories
therefore your attachment um to this
quaint religion of uh manifolds
and bundles and all of the stuff that
makes us feel good as
geometers this is just an intermediate
way of getting to the ultimate truth
which has to do
with correlation functions and quantum
measurements
now i think that's
kind of ridiculous even if you take the
classical theory to be effective it is
so
astounding in its um completeness as a
description
for the substrate of the quantum theory
in the standard model
that i think it really raises the
question
maybe this bundle structure is pretty
close to being right and that maybe
einstein's a little bit wrong
and boy if einstein were a little bit
wrong wouldn't that be great because he
a lot of the um yeah the no-go theorems
the uh think of him as your unfun uh
parent who won't let you do all the
things that you want to do
in some ways you're not going faster
than the speed of light no matter how
fast
uh you think that the ferrari should go
it's capped out
so i think it's really important to
realize that one of our best hopes for
einstein being wrong
is the idea that a true theory in a
certain sense and i'm going to say
something to make sabine crazy but it
doesn't mean what it sounds like
shouldn't have these singularities the
singular you said that they were
beautiful i thought that was interesting
because
i find them to be repugnant yeah i mean
certainly they
they are and again i don't think i've
asked you this but i've asked a lot of
guests including lenny and including sir
roger
and um and i also want to get to the
point of what do you do
when you're talking to somebody and and
you've talked to people outside of
science so
none of the people i talk to in science
are bs artists but you talk to besides
me
you do talk to people that are sometimes
accused of bs um
what do you do when you're talking to
somebody and you know they're wrong like
you know that they're not intentionally
obfuscating
they're not mendacious but they're just
wrong and and
how do you handle that as a host i mean
it's it's and i'm not
by any means i'm not comparing myself to
any of my guests i
i view myself as as simple as i said i'd
say i'd call myself a simple plumber
except for the fact
that lenny suskin was a plumber and
shelly glashau was a plumber
and uh and actually lenny worked for
shelley's father
who still has a fleet of plumbing trucks
in new york city but anyway i digress
i'm a simple experimentalist i build
things i tanker with things
but actually i'm going to defend
experimentalness later but i'm not
i'm not saying i'm brighter than these
people but i know in the case of sir
roger that he's made some
mistakes and i think those mistakes
attest to a confirmation bias that he
has
uh that i pointed out and i'm not
talking behind his back
lenny is you know i don't know him as
well but you know there were times when
i was like
i'm not sure you know if if sabine were
here if she would agree with you i'm not
saying i agree with her either
go ahead give me an example so so roger
talks about
uh the bicep two data that i played a
big part in
producing the bicep experiment that that
manifests evidence
for hawking points for the persistence
of memory of black holes
that survive through the catastrophic
end of the heat death of a previous aeon
going through to a new uh eon and he
claims there's evidence for this
in the planck data in the bicep two data
and
and so forth there's been proven i think
pretty conclusively that
neither one is true and in fact in one
case eric what he did was
um you know if the the fourier transform
of an image or the
image itself contains a lot of
information but none as much as the
hologram
of an image which from which you can
construct phase and amplitude
information
um when he what he did is try to extract
phase information from a photograph
which is fundamentally impossible and i
knew that i pointed it out to him
and he's still talking about it and by
the way the paper that i talked to
live streamed with him two weeks ago
about um and he's so
super gracious i love him to death but
that paper
um was held up in publication up until
he won a certain golden gilded piece of
guilt and and the question is you know
does that influence things i don't think
it should all right well i'm gonna make
a really
crazy argument which is irresponsible
and will probably get me thrown off of
your channel but here goes
we were just playing right yeah that's
right maybe part of the problem
it goes back to dirac's observation on
schroediger
and his point was that schroedinger
delayed publication because there was a
failure to fit with experiment
and his claim was that that's we pushed
this on people your theory
when it's found wanted you should you
should compete
and dirac said no
there was a small issue of spin which
caused the data not to conform to the
theory and its predictions
and schrodinger was unduly intimidated
by this
and so i think what i want to talk about
is
cheating and theft in the life of a
theorist
versus the life of an experimentalist
yeah let's go there
all right so here's the really crazy
idea that will immediately get me
laughed out of uh your channel
the problem is every good idea is dead
on a run
care to allow sure we have a we have a
machine
in physics for producing good ideas
if something is commutative we say maybe
it's non-commutative
if something is symmetric we say maybe
it's super symmetric maybe the symmetry
is broken
um are there four dimensions i think
there are more than four dimensions what
if there were fewer than four dimensions
we keep
varying each parameter it's very similar
actually to what the neoclassical
economists do they have a concept of a
perfect market
and then they relax the hypotheses and
they say if this failed what would be
the consequence so in a weird way
you hold up this idealized thing which
is the perfect market and then you
violate the hell out of it all the time
because that's what produces research
well where we are in physics is that
physics can't move the straightjacket
has gotten so tight that houdini can't
dislocate his wrist
to get out of and so if you start piling
on all of the experimental
indications all of the no-go theorems
all of the instances where some
brilliant person tried for 10 years and
failed to make progress on a particular
area
we've been failing for so long because
we succeeded
many years ago so well that it now
appears that we can't get to the end we
can't figure out what this is
all about in part because every
imaginative idea dies
instantly when it gets checked against
something in the mind
in the mind or in the marketplace of
ideas and data i think there's a big
difference
well so this is this thing right i
brought a guitar
and the point that i was going to make
is that you're not a string theorist
um if i pluck the string
holding my finger exactly over the
halfway point
i get a sound that vibrates at twice the
frequency
that's supposed to be almost exact if i
play
the harmonic that divides the string in
[Music]
thirds
that sounds like a perfect pythagorean
fifth
but it's not the same thing as what we
would call the even-tempered fifth your
piano
will produce a different notion of the
the note g than you would get if you
played that trick with the string and
it's off by a tiny fraction in fact you
cannot
square
compatible even temperament
uh intervals um are like quantum
mechanics
and gravity they don't yet fit together
and in fact in that case we can prove
that they can't be fit together
so my point is you could then say okay
so that fifth is not really the perfect
fifth so then we shouldn't make musical
instruments that are even tempered and
then
nothing will happen well it turns out
that that's a really bad thing to do
your piano works fine and your ear will
compensate for a certain amount of
problem and no one will ever solve it
because we can prove
mathematically it can't be solved
that means that we get to play the piano
rather than just
immediately packing up and say oh my
gosh unfortunately your
theory has faster than light
communication unfortunately
you know your theory is inconsistent
with uh observational data
from the survey of the galaxies we can
see blah blah blah
it's important to get enough space to be
imaginative and i sort of think that in
part the theorists have to steal from
the till
in order to do some business to put more
money back into the till
um by the end of the day
sorry eric your mic's breaking up a
little bit yeah it's uh i don't know if
you're on it but i actually brought this
up to lenny and i said
you know part of the reason you're so
successful is because you're not on
social media
but in reality there's some truth to
that he uh
he hates social media he feels like it's
ultimately a very pernicious
uh entity and the reason i'm bringing it
up is because i had a conversation with
paul steinhardt
more than two years ago maybe and he was
talking about and he's a very creative
he can think outside the box and he's a
member of the orthodoxy of physics at
the highest levels the einstein
professor of physics
there's that name again at princeton can
you hear me
i think it's your it might be yeah i'm
hearing you i think
people are uh mixing the audio i don't
yeah can you say something it's not
coming through again are you sure you
can't hear me i hear you now i hear you
you hear me okay um so but the point is
that you might come up with an idea
and then someone takes a picture of it
at a conference and then tweets it
around the world and you get ridiculed
so these things
become you know stillborn so to speak
um is that what you're talking about are
you talking about like actually i show
you this
this plot of data and i say you abuse
the data you violated
the the the constraints that this data
are have imposed upon
filter like for example we make maps of
the microwave sky
we're not seeing it in real time we have
a lot of filtration we have to get rid
of the ground we have to get rid of time
diurnal effects
calibration effects those are very hard
things to evade as hard as evading
you know lorenz invariants so i wonder
exactly what you mean do you mean that
like you know these things shouldn't be
subject to the same constraints that say
data analysis would put upon them well
think about it in terms of our history
there used to be something called the
tau
theta puzzle that had to do with
weak interactions and beta decay and
the tau theta puzzle sort of created a
paradox but it assumed that the universe
was symmetric in a mirror
and the solution to the tau theta puzzle
involved
what if the universe actually had a
beauty mark like marilyn monroe or cindy
crawford so that you could tell
um right so i have a i have a few moles
on my face you can tell whether that's
cool
so but i thought people would rather
think about cindy crawford
yeah that's true yeah marilyn monroe
than either one of us
so the situation there was that it was
very painful
to propose the idea that maybe the weak
force different from all other forces
would decide that it would break this
kind of mirror reflection symmetry and
who knows why
it's been one of the most astounding
discoveries in the history of physics
that that's true
but feynman gave a description of being
at a conference or something in which
some
lower ranked person said why are you
guys so keen on the idea that the
universe has to be left right symmetric
and fireman said i'm asking this
question for so and so everyone
claimed that he was doing that to
humiliate the guy because he wasn't
strong enough to do it himself feynman
says no he would have been able to but
this this gets back to the issue of
disagreeability
now disagreeability is one of the things
that
leads people to being called a-holes in
science because you don't go around
along with the crowd
i've interacted with lenny before he's
not an a-hole
but he's grumpy he's highly disagreeable
he's got the strength to say things that
other people wouldn't say
you know what's amazing about that
before you go on i asked him
i asked shelly and i asked barry barish
i said you know what thing did you not
know you know
when you were 20 that because you had
courage
to go into the impossible as is the name
of this podcast
um now you believe to be thoroughly
eminently
feasible but only because you have the
courage to go
a little bit into the impossible sure
two of the three of them
said um said it was overcoming imposter
syndrome
that basically so two of that means one
of them was a nobel prize winner
can you guess the one that wasn't that
didn't say he suffered from imposter
syndrome
what is my what is my group the group is
lenny
barry barrish and shelly glashow
um i'm going to guess that
that shelly does suffer from it
he did suffer from it and i don't know
barry bearish
it was it was actually barry and lenny
okay barry said
and this this gave me chills it gives me
chills to talk about it right now
he said when he accepted his nobel
diploma
in stockholm he was asked to sign
a book and in that book when he received
this medal he said he wasn't intimidated
by this
he was intimidated by this he saw
einstein's name
yeah he got he panicked
and i haven't released the interview but
it was one of the most deep interviews
i've ever done
and uh and it's just so touching that
this guy said no but laureate
and he could talk for hours and lenny is
like that too you know when lenny got
over
impostor syndrome he was 50 he said
full professor stanford university um
feshbach professor i think he is
national academy member
he says it's it wasn't easy and that
disagreeability
which i think you have you have a
confidence you have a swagger
and i think that that has served you but
also i think it pays to have a little
bit of insecurity
i have um a question from one of my
listeners
uh who wants to i think it's targeting
to your interview with lex friedman i
want to get to it because he paid 15
bucks
to ask this question thank you guys so
much out there it goes into my uh nobel
gelt uh collection fund uh so this is
elon elon
pay for this what's that how much did he
pay for this
he paid 15 for it and then i'll answer
it for eight
oh no you can't do it now we can't do
okay so fine no no it's
it's a jewish joke anyway keep going
you're trying to undercut the
marketplace
elon tusk is asking eric when you say
it's time we got off this planet
please explain to us which i think you
did with lex friedman please explain to
us what this looks like
if my less successful cousin elon musk
were to
implement this technology assuming it's
possible to his ship so in other words
what does it look like to get off this
planet i guess he's not asking the
question i would ask elon
you should have asked this question why
is eric concerned with getting off this
plant but
he just asked you the technical question
sorry i can't hear you
give me a response in the chat room can
you hear me in the chat room
i don't hear i
don't hear eric i have not changed
anything
is anyone here me
please type in the chat room if you hear
me
and oh elon is a jew as well interesting
i don't know
uh nobody's perfect just kidding uh so
eric you hear me
i don't hear you does anyone in the chat
room here brian
please let me know
uh elon's technology took us offline all
right it looks like he's coming back
uh you don't hear eric but you hear me
so i will
now play my guitar no i can't play
anything
the only instrument i play is the iphone
and i don't even play that very well all
right let me call eric back
yes you guys are all saying i'm going to
tell this to eric i'm going to tell eric
eric are you there can you hear me
eric active now he has to invest some of
elon tusks
money into a microphone eric can you
hear me
i can hear you okay now i can hear you
okay so elon is giving us this money
and i want you to use it to get yourself
a quality microphone
right here and this is uh this is this
is good okay everyone in the chat room
tell me if you can hear eric
now you guys all hear me okay good it's
time you guys talk at the same time eric
falls off anyway so now
i've changed my microphone my microphone
my camera and people are going to be
angry because my dell computer is going
to be looking up my nose you're going to
see that comment a lot
i've only heard that the only thing i've
heard more than that is when is eric
going to publish his theory of geometric
unity
that is verboten we're not talking about
that today folks okay
all right how do we get off this planet
just how not why how
well i think part of it would have to do
with using degrees of freedom
that if there is a way if there is any
first you know there's like a lot of ifs
so just assume that we go through the
boilerplate
so that the theory was right assume that
in
in some sense 14 dimensions somewhat
replaces four dimensions we
have now 10 extra dimensions it might be
that you'd be able to travel along those
10 extra dimensions rather than along
the four and it might be then
much more economical let's say to come
up
you know to move along the ten
dimensions then move along the four
where it's easier and then to go back up
the ten and now you're somehow
farther apart um i mean i don't even
know whether that's a sensible thing but
the key thing is we're a bunch of
co-traveling waves
and in my estimation we think we're
co-traveling waves in four dimensions
but we're actually co-traveling waves in
a
larger space and that larger space
in includes the rulers and protractors
of einstein's space-time metric
and so if those are actually legitimate
degrees of freedom
try to imagine like you could at least
theoretically you could imagine
if i shrink all of the distances by
expanding the rulers
then suddenly you know my first
operation might be expand the rulers
and then move in that new world where
you know
a mile is now an inch and then contract
the rulers so that would be the kind of
uh by incorporating the space time
metric is one of the degrees of freedom
on which waves can propagate
there might be something to do like that
but the key point is you need to know
what the full source code is
before you know what you can and cannot
do
if we have our current pictures a bunch
of effective theories you might have no
go theorems in the effective
theory that aren't no go theorems in the
ultimate theory
and so the question is does the ultimate
theory inherit the same set of
restrictions
as we currently have in our partial
theories known as general relativity in
the standard model
i hope that was worth your 15 all right
well now we have a bidding war because
someone is
uh asking a 20 question uh see it's very
profit this is why i do these
uh these these super chats okay uh this
is from a man who has a name and i
promise not to sing for 50.
well i was saying you know you asked me
if i can play any someone's asking if i
can play an instrument i said yes i
played the iphone
uh but not very well a super chat from a
man or woman by the name of
r maybe it's the software anyway two
questions so he wants her she wants two
questions
what is the role of category theory in
physics and what do you think about
teaching advanced mathematics
using computers for example use
mathematica we're going to get to our
conversation with stephen wolfram
not too long from now and sagemath i'm
not familiar with that
to teach advanced differential geometry
so two questions
category theory i guess should we teach
it at a
yearly age when we teach you know
calculus or
and then also what's the role of
computers in the teaching pedagogy of
mathematics
thank you r so first of all for those
who are not familiar with category
theory category theory sort of got
forced almost on the mathematics
community because you would notice that
certain patterns were highly conserved
so something that seems to be about
algebra and like the algebra of
symmetries
might also be true for spaces and
geometric
objects and so you would notice that
certain relationships
in very different sounding places were
were carried over
categories of things are in fact
um related to each other through things
called
functors which are sort of like maps of
theories to other theories
in essence we do category theory for two
reasons
one we do it to clean things up and to
get to the
the heart and elucidate what's really
going on at the purest level
not to be distracted by the
instantiations which may
appear different but you know it's the
same thing in different guys
same sort of underlying it's sort of a
way of dealing with platonic truths
rather than
examples of truths the other reason we
often do it is to avoid work
we don't know what to do so we say okay
well how does that work
category theoretically maybe we should
use two categories or three categories
you make things more and more
abstract to avoid a reckoning
and so there's a good reason to do
category theory which is usually not
essential but it's very helpful if you
know how to do it
and then there's this other thing that
we do which is that we sort of go into
you know mathematicians have this phrase
they call it abstract nonsense sometimes
affectionately sometimes
in a derisive way how does it relate to
physics
well what we have i mean a good example
of this would be quantum field theory
in in a weird way quantum field theory
takes initial states and asks about the
transition to final states
um but we have another geometric theory
called borderism
theory where you have an incoming
manifold and an outgoing manifold that
looked like incoming and outgoing states
and then in the 1980s and early 90s we
sort of found out that these two things
were the same and that kind of category
theoretic
version of uh of some sort of
equivalence where something quantum
field theoretic and something
differential topological were actually
the same
underlying thing so i think that there's
lots of things that category
category can theory can do if you have
to have
a very nice formulation of a theory that
makes sense as rich mathematics i also
think that it's a way of avoiding
our more fundamental problems in the
subject so
i hope some of you will not listen to me
and will show me that category theory
actually
breaks the law now i should point out
that you and i
have formed a partnership a super group
which also will involve a certain young
weinstein
not young einstein but a young weinstein
uh and that we are working on the second
part of
ours question which is about teaching
pedagogy and mathematics uh does the
computer enhance it
and i don't know about sage math but we
we had a live debate this summer
with stephen wolfram i'll put that in
the chat room right now but
uh just so people can refer to it by the
way everyone's out there sitting down
your fingers are getting numb and at
risk this is my advertisement now okay
eric here
now we're gonna make some real money uh
your fingers can get carpal tunnel
syndrome unless they're exercised so
please take your finger
stick it on the subscribe button to this
channel and that will do me a big favor
uh because we want to get more attention
for live streams just like this
and the one that we did this summer
what's that
love the hustle gotta hustle gotta
hustle okay
so what do you think about teaching
young zev and others mathematics
by using mathematica for example by our
our friend and compatriot in all things
theoretical of uh theories of everything
mr dr stephen wolfram i think it's
great but you have to know what some of
the problems with it
are so one one thing i would say for
example is that
let's imagine that you have a matrix
a a matrix with two rows and three
columns
sometimes in the computer it makes a
difference as to whether it's
um if it's three rows of two columns or
if it's two columns of three rows you
know
in some weird way that's irrelevant to
the mathematics but makes sense as to
how the memory is allocated
inside of the computer so i think it's
very important
to make sure that whatever you're doing
in a
pedagogical fashion using the technology
you keep track of the ways in which the
technology actually
fails to mirror reality for example in
the original
formulation of python there was a
problem with the ring of integers where
the brilliant founder of python guido
van rossum
had an idea that the
the product of two num of two integers
is an integer so that the
uh if you divide one number by another
you should
stay in the same class but if you divide
seven by three
that's not an integer and so he cast it
to the nearest integer
that was an example of something where
you thought you understood what you were
doing inside of the computer i'm
dividing seven by three
but you might find out that you're
you're going to get
either the number two
uh or the number three unexpectedly
so you have to keep track of what it is
that the computer is
actually doing versus what did you think
it was doing but i think it's a great
you know
sage maxima um
wolfram's mathematica project i would
also point to our friends in
austin continuum research with the
anaconda release of scientific python
are all of these are very helpful tools
but
don't you know just know know where
the map between the real map and the
computer's representation of it breaks
down
okay we have another uh friend this time
across the pond i presume
uh walter bishop uh chipping in with a
five
pound note question for brian and eric
up to what point do you agree with
string theorists before the disagreement
branches out um so i want to say before
i ask that question i asked shelly
glashau
this week author of this really
wonderful book that i want uh this copy
is for zeb when he comes down to visit
um i want to know i want to know he has
a scorecard he has a rubric and i'm
going to go all through it with you
to ask uh what in the pre in the 32
years since this book was written it's a
wonderful book it's
actually probably the best book on the
pedagogy of elementary particle physics
of unification and we went through in
this video i'll post probably next week
and remind her i'm going to have people
on i'm trying to get gerard hoofed
i hope i'm saying that right i'm hoping
to get the big dog
who knows yeah i think it is i think i'm
going to try to get ed whitton speaking
of string theory as walter bishop i'm
going to try but
i'm going to need a lot of help out
there because he doesn't do podcast
or so he says anyway what's that
edwin did one he did one yes yes he did
one
you have to rub that in thanks eric
thank you um
you're the only ew who comes on the
podcast um
so why are there some people edwin
now you never read this book but you
actually resonate very well with
it so here's the first thing that you
and i ever talked about
why are there so many basic particles
why are there so many free parameters
why does the number three play such a
big role in elementary particles
and uh how many families are there all
told so he asked these questions
presuming he'd find out answers you know
before the year 2000
let alone the year 2020 hopefully may it
be gone and
forgotten soon although i'm hoping it's
been 57.80 that was the problem now
we're in 57.81
things are smooth anyway what do you
make of this that we haven't made
progress since this book was written and
not for lack of spending money and then
i'm going to give you something really
pro
i'm going to say it's a good thing that
the ssc was canceled but for now
please answer this question what what
grade would you give these three
different problems
why are there so many particles why are
there so many free parameters why does
the number three come in
what grades would you give to
theoretical particle physics
well it depends what you mean so let's
do the first one why are there so many
particles
yes um i would say that he's saying that
the number three matters because there's
three collections of 16 particles with
sort of
four space-time states a piece
so that's all of that is coming from
um trying to figure out how to say this
to a partially lay audience but
in essence we have these four gadgets
called lee groups never mind they're
collections of symmetry but the full
name of it would be sl2c
cross su 3 crest su 2 cross u1
and then you have to specify a particle
by
giving some idea of what those
groups of symmetries symmetrize in the
form of something called a vector space
now it turns out that
partially due to shell i mean there's a
there's a hidden kind of agenda almost
in this maybe
which is that shelley was one of the
first people to talk about so-called
grand unified theories now because we
have to make everything difficult
uh for the guests like me in theoretical
physics you'd think grand unified was
more
unified than unified but it's less
unified it's only three out of four
horses so we do that to throw off i know
the russians in case they're going to
invade or something like that we don't
know
so you have this weird thing which is
that shelly
um figured out a model called su5
which reduced the numbers of particles
in essence the space
stayed 16 dimensional uh
but it really broke up as one plus five
plus ten
then there was another theory called
so10 which again should have been called
spin 10
but the physicists have the wrong name i
don't know why they do that to me
and what they do is they put everything
in one 16-dimensional
symmetric situation so the number of
particles goes down
in a certain sense but the space of the
particle
expand
i think it's if you believe in the
so-called so-10 which is really spin 10
theory
and then there's a different version of
this called
salon you can grade me to see whether
i'm a good tourist here
that theory is very similar to the so-10
theory
but it's slightly different it makes use
of something called spin six cross spin
four otherwise known as
su four cross uh
su two process u2 never mind that
theory um both of those indicate that
there's a lot more unification we just
haven't
seen that it's true yet so i think that
the idea is that we actually have a
speculation
that there are fewer particles in a
certain sense once you heat things up to
see the hidden symmetry and that they're
just
fewer numbers of more capacious
um articles
in a certain technical sense the number
three is mysterious because of the
number of
ex generations experienced
people think that they've seen three
copies of lego imagine that you had a
lego set made of plastic one made of
wood one made of lead
the lego would sort of be the same shape
but the weight
of each set of lego would be different
now is there a tungsten platinum set
is there you know is there some other
platinum set is there some lego set
beyond the three that we know about
i actually claim that we only have two
generations of matter
um and what because what's really
happening
in my mind is that for something to be a
true generation
it shouldn't just be a generation at low
energy it should retain the same
properties as the others when you heat
them up so if you have three things that
look
the same when they're cold
but only two of them look the same once
they're heated up
then you might have only two generations
or maybe there's only one unique
generation and there's three different
versions of it they all look the same
when they're cold
so i've never heard anyone in my life
say that i don't know why
but i believe that that's a consequence
of my theory
that there are only two generations not
three whereas everyone else would say we
know that there are three maybe there
are more but we there are limits on it
from astrophysics
um what's the fine what are the other
questions uh
well the number three why are there so
many parameters why are there so many
particles
um there are some things that there is a
grade that i would say is higher than an
f minus which i used to get a lot of in
in high school
uh such as you know are the our
neutrinos massless he asked that
question back in 1988 now we know
they're not massless at least one of
them has a mask
we know that surprisingly from
astrophysical experiments not unlike the
ones that my colleagues and i do on the
simon's observatory etc
cosmic microwave background baron
acoustic oscillations etc
people are asking um so we got a 50
krona i don't know i think that's about
seven dollars i'm not sure
uh 50 kroner uh a question uh actually
it's not a question it's just how to
pronounce
that so thank you very much from norway
for that
people are are questioning again
how do we fit and reconcile the need for
something
when there may not even be evidence of
lack
in other words is there a lacuna in
physics when if
if the old one is einstein called god
hands us a piece of paper
and it says there are no singularities
at the center of black holes and there
was no singularity in the early universe
sir rogers right again and uh and uh or
or or sir paul steinhardt is right
there is no singularity would you give
up gu
sorry i don't think there is a singular
okay so so singularities
are not part of the motivation to unify
gravity with the
other higher energy forces well this is
this is the uncomfortable part
one of the problems is that we love
einstein a little too much
you know we sort of treat our great
physicists as heroes and then we make
the mistake of taking
the top of our pile and they stop
looking like the rest of us i don't
think that newton
and einstein have the same sort of feel
even drock
i mean weirdly maxwell i think you know
did this unbelievable work but i don't
think that we live in terror maxwell i
don't know why that is maybe it's too
far
back um weirdly newton because of the
calculus
everybody's in awe i think that the
great fear
is that we're afraid to challenge
einstein
most people who challenge einstein do it
because they don't
it's sort of like picking a fight with
khabib nurmagomedov
if you were smarter you wouldn't do it
so dumb people pick fights with like
the most dangerous people remember that
yeah i always compare it to like
dungeons and dragons i get these emails
literally every day i'm sure you get
them too and it's like professor keating
uh einstein was wrong i can prove uh how
and if you help me i will share my
portion of the nobel prize with you
and uh i told that to adam reese who won
the 2011 nobel prize
and he said yeah how do you think i got
this you know i answered one of those
emails
um someone's asking a young weinstein
let's say there was young whites like
i wanted to get to the previous oh yeah
finish that yeah and then we'll get to
it so
the point is that the singularities give
me confidence that einstein isn't the
last word that he's
he's correct in his domain but
that you know he had this wonderful
thing about uh
his aphorism about my equation is like a
house
um with two wings one made of fine
marble the other made of cheap wood
and one side of it comes from curvature
in geometry and that was the marble side
then the other side was like you just
throw together whatever it is that
creates something called the stress
energy tensor and i always thought okay
what does a contrarian do the contrarian
imagines that the problem is with the
marble
and is there a body buried under the
marble is is einstein are we so afraid
to talk about einstein's greatest
achievement that we were we're giving
him a kind of reverence that's holding
us back and so i think you you both have
to sort of go after einstein but it's
going to be imperative that you restore
him once you take him down from his
pedestal and none of us really want to
do it because
quite frankly we love him and we love
him because
he was everything we wanted to be he was
right about the most important crazy
things
he was decent he was wise
you know so no it's true but
yeah i mean sometimes you have to kill
your father and you know well
i don't know what what do you do after
that but so you're you're going to take
over my son's tutelage and tell him that
great
no no you will withdraw your tuition
singularities give me confidence to say
i don't think that einstein is the last
word
and i don't think non-physicists and
mathematicians
um it's it's a little bit weird that
we're so reverent for one of our own
where there's still people walking
around who met him
and i think we just we
we haven't gotten over our outstanding
yeah and
we won't until he's made into an
effective theory and that's coming
and even yeah even as i said the the
great uh nobel laureates and the
others still suffer from from imposter
syndrome when they get confronted with
even just seeing his signature gives
them
yeah i mean what else is it but by the
way eric i mean
i also feel like and you know from my
book losing the nobel prize
that i feel like this medallion and even
the recognition the hero worship
is a form of of of idolatry i feel like
we worship people
and ironically we fast many of us
profess to be agnostic or
downright atheist uh lenny uh as a
hardcore atheist
and and yet when we were talking and
this happened with gad sad i had gatsat
on my channel
who's a devout practicing atheist and he
was quoting things
basically unknowingly quoting from the
shema
and from and from other canons of
judaism and christianity
and and so was a leni lenny said what's
the most important thing because i ask
all my guests as i'm going to ask you in
about 15 20 minutes
you know what would you put in your zava
ah and your ethical will
not your material will i know most of
that's coming to me uh when you're 120
but uh that good teal scratch it's
coming my way baby
but i want to know what you put in your
ethical will shelley refused to answer
that question
uh glashow he would not answer that
question the first time it's ever
happened to me it's
kind of awkward to be honest with you uh
but barry answered that question and
lenny answered it basically as justice
justice you shall pursue
now these are these atheists they're all
jewish it happens to be there have been
some jews and um there have been many
people believing moz i've had on marwah
eldwinnie i have to give her a shout out
she's your biggest fan she wants you on
her podcast even more than me
uh which he had on so uh she's a devout
muslim
and uh and these these most of
scientists aren't you know
are would believe and profess to be
atheist and yet they worship
galileo they worship uh oh eric has been
knocked off the channel just as we were
talking about god can you hear me
what are you you there can you hear me
yeah i hear you i'm here
okay so what do you make of this hero
worship is it hero worship like we want
to feel like there are people that are
the super ninjas
of the brain and that like jack
nicholson said you want me on that wall
you need me on that we need them what do
you think
um i don't know i mean i feel like i've
seen
i've met my heroes and they survived
and you survived you know i i used to
hang out with this guy isabora's singer
isaac bishop a singer's cousin
at mit and you you don't find people at
that level of intelligence
in everyday life it's true it's real you
know
every week you have lunch with the same
person i i rarely sort of don't have
this fear of hero worship
my feeling is you don't know what the
human mind is capable of
until you get into a small number of
areas
that prove you know i mean look at eddie
van halen and arctatum prove
and albert einstein yeah they're just
certain things
the mind can do that nobody's prepared
for when you've met
somebody who's touched the cosmos in
that way
they are altered yeah and yet they put
their pants on you know one leg at a
time right
eric your microphone is a little uh
scratchy can you uh
is there anything you could do to it
people are saying how slim you're
looking maybe that's causing it
i'll use this option to remind people to
take out their fingers
stretch your digits regularly push the
subscribe button
on this channel so we can grow and
continue to get guests like
ed whitton hopefully someday another ew
and i'm going to ask drew's question i
think this is a fascinating question
what area of stem
is most ripe for disruption or paradigm
shifts
in other words i'm going to ask that in
terms of where would he advise his
his children to go into and my children
to go into
what field of of science is most ripe
for
disruption eric can you hear me i can't
can you hear me
yeah it's very scratchy can you want to
use your phone people are saying to use
your phone maybe let's try that do you
have your skype your phone nearby
uh i do um let me see what's battery
situation oh three percent
well done um
these theorists
let me let me see if i can
uh is that any better that's much better
yeah yeah much better okay okay good
all right so where would you uh send
your children or my children what area
of stem
is most ripe for a paradigm ship shift
or disruption
well i mean obviously the things that
are new and have a lot of novelty
are what get people so you're going to
see a lot of machining machine learning
a lot of distributed computing
you're going to see a certain amount um
looks kind of new and exciting uh
well look i'm going to go in an opposite
direction
i think it's theoretical physics and
fundamental physics that that
and i think that there's no indication
that this is about to happen
that is generic and that's why i feel
excited to predict that a stagnant field
is going to move
um but i think it's been pretty stagnant
for a very long time
again there are a lot of caveats to the
word stagnant in that sentence
yeah but um i don't think
that it's easy look nothing is working
the way it should
you can't get a phd in any field that
i'm aware of and have an expectation
that you're going to become a professor
yeah extremely unlikely nowadays yeah so
i think that
in part we just have to recognize that
we
have got to take the system back we got
to get tons of money
to our best people we've got to stop
killing off
everybody who you know gives it a shot
either by
bouncing them out of the field or
working them to the bone or threatening
them that if they don't follow the
fashion they can't be employed
we have a terrible situation and it's up
to people like you and me
uh brian to let the people who've been
in charge of this
for too long we have to tell them your
time is up it's over
we need to revitalize these fields these
need to be careers
these aren't um it shouldn't be that you
spend
you know your life to age 35 before you
find out that you know
you're not even employable and you can't
have children and your spouse can't live
in the same state as you
this is preposterous and i think i'm
just sort of embarrassed about the
question
and the richest nation uh in the history
of the world i'm actually i'm actually
telling you don't go into science when
you desperately need it come on yeah i
want to
i want to make a provocative statement
yeah are you on your phone by the way
where are you on now because we don't
see your your lovely visage
uh to some is that right well i hear you
great but i don't see you at all there
you are
okay it's a little scratchy still yeah
but i think that the problem is is that
don't send your kids into stem until
brian and i get to the national academy
of sciences
and turn over a few people and shake
money out of their pockets into the
coffers
uh to pay for young people to actually
have careers
with stability and freedom
it's also incredibly important that we
get some of the transparency out of the
field because
you need the freedom to think crazy
thoughts we are doing
safe science and i personally think that
our desire to not
waste taxpayer money is wasting taxpayer
money
what you need to do is to give the money
to people who are dangerous
people who are original let them figure
out who they need to fund
make sure that it's not such a cutthroat
environment
and let's get on with it and get back to
being americans is the greatest
scientific country in the world
so i want to uh conclude with a couple
things uh that are on my mind one is
very provocative
which is that i was talking to barry
barish winner of the 2017 nobel prize
for detection of gravitational waves
using ligo very wonderful man he was
working on a project called the
superconducting supercollider
and they had been working on that for
many years and then it got canceled in
1993
congress canceled it uh i make the
statement that that's a good thing
and in fact perhaps he wouldn't have won
the nobel prize
uh and maybe ligo would never have
succeeded because he was
the decisive person along with ray weiss
who will be on the podcast too
another reason to subscribe he's coming
on the podcast soon these are guys who
are getting up there i'm trying to get
women by the way and they just they just
won't come on the show
i don't know why uh well i know why i
asked donna strickland who is a hero of
mine
i had john allen i'm saying nobel women
there aren't many uh but i'm trying my
best to have them on because i
really want to feature them because i
have a lot to learn from them and
we both have daughters and we want to be
inspired and our sons too
but anyway um she just doesn't do
podcasts she said
and i'm trying to get a hold of andrea
guez who's a colleague at ucla but it's
been tough anyway
i want to get back to this ssc
cancellation my controversial opinion is
it was good
because europe ended up doing it it was
built to detect one thing which is the
higgs boson effectively i mean people
can argue with me
cost 20 billion dollars when you
actually add up the money and by the way
whenever a physicist tells you if
something is going to cost x billion
dollars always double it
because to operate it costs as much as
to build it over 10 years cost 10
percent per year
to operate of the construction cost
that's operations rule of thumb number
101
so if he had stayed on the
superconducting super collider we would
have spent 20 maybe 30 billion dollars
we would have detected the same thing
maybe a little bit earlier maybe not
and he wouldn't have worked on ligo and
ligo wouldn't have succeeded
so it's a good thing that ligo that ssc
got cancelled what do you say
why okay tell me where i'm where i'm
lost
well first of all we pissed off congress
and we lied to congress about
a science shortage and if you uh
um if you take for example our mutual
friend rabbi walpi
uh his cousin howard walthey held
hearings
and the basic question was why did you
the national science foundation and you
the national academy of sciences
lie to us you had a special deal with us
and you stupid effing morons
uh in fact concocted this scheme
to um for some reason that we can't
figure out to do shitty science
inside the national science foundation
national academy of science you
bamboozled us
you got us to pass the immigration act
of 1990 and then we find out that in
fact this is an incompetent demographic
study because it didn't take demand
in the labor marketing this is the same
time that they also said what are you
doing buying art for the ssc at these
prices
and quite honestly i'm incredibly
disappointed
with the senior leadership of the
physics community
for one not understanding the political
sensibilities
in washington but also not leveling with
them which is
you take our toys away from us you're
going to screw yourself over
in effect we have intellectual seal team
6 at your disposal
and what we like to do is to train and
work out we work on physics but we're
available to you guys
and this is an advanced technological
nation that brought forth atomic
weaponry
you need your best and brightest to go
into these fields
and to make sure that you're current
given for example that you know
the world wide web for example came out
of cern
um there is no question in my mind
that if you try to do a cost benefit
analysis and why are we spending so much
money to look for particles for these
people
you're getting it wrong um we're at the
almost the end of perhaps the greatest
story in the history of the world
and we're acting like a bunch of cusses
and
20 billion dollars is not that much
for the people who helped in world war
ii with two
monstrous weapons dropped on our now
allied japan which is
incredibly horrific for all those who
died but it was also
the decisive end to world war ii
uh your communications devices the
semiconductors in your phone
almost all of this comes from
theoretical physics as much as i
and i really often dislike dealing with
theoretical physicists
but it's like i'm sure i wouldn't seal
team six they'd probably think i was a
[ __ ]
on the other hand do i want seal team
six to be well funded and to be there
whenever i need them absolutely well
this is what it takes to get the world's
smartest engineers the best
mathematicians
the world's top physicists and minds
working together
to be available to our government in our
country when we need it
and to make progress and potentially you
know
let me turn it on you guys you guys
brought us into the valley of death
and the only people who are going to get
us out of the valley of death after the
atomic weapons of world war ii and then
the fusion devices that
followed in the early 50s the only
people are going to get us off the
planet
are physicists elon started as a
physicist but those rocket engines
aren't
good enough to get us diversity beyond
the solar system we need a huge number
of different
planets to experiment with so that we
don't all go up in one
fell swoop on the on the one that we
have
so the short answer is
we pissed off the government we changed
our agreement with them
catastrophically it was part of two
separate sets of hearings
and quite frankly i think um it's the
mismanagement of the physics community's
legacy by senior physicists and it's
it's a it was a horrific thing to lose
so i want to give some news to folks
that we are going to be
working together uh on a on a project
for
revitalization and cut in and in concert
experiment and theory working together
eric and i
have plans for this stay tuned for that
uh again please subscribe to eric's
channel
the portal the portal clips and listen
to episodes i believe
i will be on an episode in the not too
distant future before the
universe doubles in size we've recorded
an episode
someday that will be uh available and i
want to thank eric for that
i want to close with a couple more
questions from the audience we have one
uh from russia with love and that if i
can find it
by the way just to come back to at the
very end let's come back to the question
about what to do with a guest who says
something that you
don't feel comfortable let's do that now
because because yeah time is running out
uh the day is short
i want to i want to know yeah i'm
dealing with guests and and this week
was this kind of up and down roller
coaster for me i had just being honest
i had wonderful guests that were were
really um
edgy interesting controversial but don't
even care about their legacy
i had other guests on this week that are
very considerate of how their reputation
is handled and not wanting to be too
controversial even when i know that they
have controversial opinions and i'm not
like
here to be jerry springer of physics but
the bottom line is i think that they
sometimes will manage an image in a way
that is contrary to what is best for
at least my audience now maybe they
don't care about my audience and who why
should they
oh we've lost eric but we haven't lost
me
i will keep going so the existential
crisis that i faced is whether or not to
involve
um eric can you hear me yes brian sorry
you
i you said you had guests on you had a a
tough week and then i couldn't hear
anymore yeah no just just having guests
that are that are generous with an
open and willing to be vulnerable and i
think that those are the most
interesting people
and they help demystify the einstein
syndrome that we were both decrying
and and when i'm dealing with that i'm
like in real time first of all i want to
know eric
when you're interviewing somebody do you
have a metric that you're using like i'm
doing a good job with this interview
or i'm doing a bad job i found i i have
one or two but i want to hear what are
your tips as podcasters
especially with really intellectual
guests that you get on excluding me
i haven't solved this puzzle i talk over
people too much i'm too aggressive
sometimes i don't want to embarrass
somebody and i
maybe shortchange the intellectual
sometimes i want to do the intellectual
right i feel like i didn't
take care of the person properly there's
a huge number of competing pressures
and i think people see us failing at one
thing or the other they don't realize
that
it's not because we didn't consider
maybe i should shut up maybe i should
let people finish it's sort of like
wow if i don't if i don't say something
then this is going to go on for a
20-minute rift and we're going to lose
the audience
you know okay so in this situation you
know
i had a little bit of this situation
with garrett lisey i
i like garrett and i care about him i
think he's very imaginative and i think
he brought a lot of good ideas
into the world even though i think his
theory is wrong i don't make a
secret of saying that his theory is
wrong and but you know it's clear that i
hold him
uh you know in high regard as a human
being
that he's generative that he's original
that he's trying all sorts of positive
things
when i interviewed him i guess he had
decided that he had moved from e8 to an
infinite dimensional
version of his own theory and that this
was the solution of the problem
and it was a significant enough pivot
that i didn't know how to
address it entirely
because i sort of felt like you should
at least acknowledge
that the other thing didn't work and
maybe this pivot works but you know one
of the problems in startups is that if
you keep pivoting
then you know the question is was there
something there
at all and i think that you know garrett
had a really interesting good idea
that doesn't work um
in the case of uh you know in rogers
case you know i interacted with him and
there were some places where
i feel like we didn't have a satisfying
intellectual connection so i think that
that's
normal but i think that when you when
you love people and your friends like
it's possible that you and i could talk
about geometric unity
and you would say wasn't that a minus
sign i'll say no no
oh is it oh really did 35 years of work
just
go out the window it it's a nightmare
and it's funny
it's it's it's hysterically funny that
we live our lives like this but the
thing is what else
can we do i mean at least we're trying
at least
as a theoretical physicist or
mathematician looking at this stuff
you're trying
and if you fail all that can be said is
nobody else figured it out either
yeah you failed daring greatly like uh
teddy roosevelt said so
when i'm doing something i want to get
your opinion about if i'm interviewing
you or i mean you and i are good friends
but but if i'm
interviewing a hostile witness and and i
hear them say something like um
that's a good question i kind of think
that that is a good question whereas i
hear them say
well as i said before you know then i
realized i'm not doing so great
or similarly when somebody says like
they just stop
and think and i'd let them try to like
hang them
like not hang themselves but i let the
silence do the work and and i wondered
like
do you have this loop in your head to to
be a good interviewer we're not trained
in this we're doing the best we can
see i try to embrace things like you
know you
said impostor syndrome i've listed my
occupation as imposter on
numerous occasions uh you know i talk
all the time about the fact that i'm not
a physicist and here i am of pining on
these shows and blah blah blah
in all of these circumstances you have
to
sort of play with it and make fun of it
like you know i'll be honest when you
said lenny suskin it obvious
was obviously incredibly successful
i had a moment where i said busy
you know i mean i understand that he's
very highly regarded and he's
contributed many theories but does it
cash out
properly you know if i were to list
kumar and vapha if i were to list ed
who's going to be a guest next week yeah
that's a good question i have a question
for you let me i'm sorry to interrupt
but i but time is short and i do want to
get to a few things for you
and maybe we'll do this again next week
but but the point eric is
um i say this another provocative thing
which you'll probably shoot me down for
but
i say it wouldn't make a difference if
electro week unification was discovered
in 1962
as it was by shelley glacial and
collaborators
or if it was discovered in 1982 but it
would have made a big difference if the
transistor
wasn't discovered in 1956 uh and instead
was discovered in 1976
so i think that there is sort of a
fungibility in some sense of
of theory in other words theory is going
to be discovered
you know but but experimental or
inventions which is what alfred nobel
wanted to
recognize i mean what do you say about
that that there's sort of this time and
time value of money and that we really
should invest it purely in experimental
physics and not any in theoretical
science i mean nobody looked at the
quantum mechanical laws of schroedinger
said let's build a transistor
these are some guys fritzing around in a
garage and if you look at the original
transistor
it's chewing gum it's a coat hanger it's
a crystal
it's pretty wacky stuff and nobody like
looked at the schrodinger equation to
solve it
oh boy do i have a different impression
yes i mean my life is so determined in
part
by the synthesis that it occurred
by the mid 70s and if it weren't for
jim simons uh and cn yang
at the state university of new york at
stony brook figuring this out
my life would be completely different i
think that
you know so many things hinged on the
fact that the
glacial weinberg salaam model
with and speaking of it hooked you know
showing the renormalizability of these
gauge theories and the way in which all
of the stuff conspired
is incredibly important from allowing
others
fields to progress in particular
differential geometry and topology in
this beautiful renaissance so i think it
actually was super important
that this stuff should have been
discovered earlier it would have been
nicer if when
when yang and mills was at 1954 53
something like that came out with their
theory that if they had understood it to
be geometric
i really think it's a tragedy that we
don't have cn yang on our lips whenever
i hear people say that
stephen weinberger edwin is the world's
greatest living theoretical physicist
i always say i'm waiting for the day
when another name
is as added to that and cn yang is my
favorite
um i'm gonna try to get him on the show
godspeed but look you know in part i
think it actually really does matter the
problem
is is that it's a story to which almost
no one is paying attention and if we're
going to get off this planet
we are going to need a fundamental
theory you're going to want those
theorists on
you know in in jack nicholson's uh
you're going to want those theorists on
that wall actually the wall is at stony
brook and you and i are gonna go in with
a chisel one night
and chisel some equations on the wall
okay we have a few minutes left
uh any other questions i want to scan
quickly through make sure people got
their money's worth but while i'm doing
that eric
i want i want to ask you a question that
i asked
um this is from allison walker quick one
thanks what's written on top of a purple
heart okay i don't know what that means
but allison is a good friend of the show
thank you i want to know if you
subscribe to this notion of the ethical
will and i asked this of all my guests i
asked this of jim simons to john 11 to
almost anybody that's come on the
podcast and um
and i want to know in your opinion if if
you were to leave
a legacy uh not of material goods
but an ethical will a will of wisdom a
will of exp based on your experience
that would be not only for your
biological children and grandchildren
may there be many but also for your
ideological children
of which there are already you realize
you make a huge impact
on the world eric and what you say
people listen to and pay to hear
uh and uh and i get it i get it for free
and i should reimburse you someday
i'll pay you that three bitcoins that i
promised you 20 years ago
but anyway what would you leave in your
ethical will and then we'll finish up
with a question from our friend tyler
i mean i think what i believe is uh look
the only thing that i've ever done in my
life
that has the ability even potentially to
compete
um for the attention of people a
thousand years from now
would be geometric unity and
it's quite possible that it's just wrong
um you know
i don't think it is i'm betting heavily
on it
that would probably be the first thing
and what that thing is is it's about
hope it's about
all sorts of crazy human motivations it
was an incredibly self-destructive
undertaking
um and i i worry about communicating it
to my son
which is do i want to tell you to try to
do something at all
against all odds money's no
object health is no object i mean my
guess is that i was probably overweight
for a large number of years
in part because i had stopped thinking
of myself as a member of this planet
which is probably incredibly unhealthy
and delusional
potentially you feel like that was
intentional i mean for me i'm addicted
to food i eat too much because
of course but my point is that i sort of
checked out and um
yeah i mean i really when i talk about
this twin nuclei problem i'm not kidding
around i really do believe we're all
wearing face masks potentially because
of
something that might have come out of
the wuhan institute of virology
the thing gives me the most confidence
is just how certain i'm not supposed to
say
that uh youtube and the federal
government is you know so i don't know
whether we're going to have a problem
with nuclear weapons i don't know
whether we're gonna have a problem
with these viruses but we have to get
out of here because we've outgrown this
planet
and we're too powerful and we're not
smart enough our politics is a mess
and we've got to spread out because we
can't have one correlated experiment so
that's
that the core of my ethical will is that
now i speak a lot on a lot of different
programs and one of the things that i
feel very confident of is that my if my
children ever choose to pay attention to
me again
there will be a huge corpus
of audio and video that indicate
what did i what did i think what did i
think about politics what did i think
about decency what did i think about
um you know how we treated uh
homosexuals uh years ago and we wouldn't
allow them to marry i
i think i've opined on so many things
that if were i to die this instant
there would be a huge record of my
thinking
and i think too as i've told you you
know what if you stumbled upon something
from the shtetls of eastern europe and
it said you know
great grandma nahama weinstein uh and
you found this book
and they they said it's gonna be a
hundred bitcoin
you would pay it and so i want you to
think about your children's children's
children
and think about putting something in
writing because we have books from
galileo
we have books from
from right you're lying you're trying
you've been trying to get me to write a
book for ages and now you're pressuring
me and you're nagging me
on international television i'm just
saying people are out there okay people
are asking
what's it what is lex friedman like and
uh
what what what is his uniqueness in the
role of the podcasting world and then
one comment brilliant gorgeous and
ladies he's single
and uh tyler is asking a question i'm
trying to find tyler goodstein
goldstein has a question and i want to
get to that
uh allison no no no no no
rapid fire let's do rapid fire yeah okay
uh
um vulnerability is kind of we'll
realize that space-time let me see here
you need to take the energy out brian
what's that take the energy out
okay okay okay uh what do you think
about girdle
girdles incompleteness theorem i never
wear them
uh sorry i think that it's it's
fabulously interesting but i i think
that we tend to do it too much as a g
whiz i'm sure that there's a formal
formal
way of saying it that sounds more like
there's certain things that are true for
good reasons there's certain other
things that happen to be true but they
don't have a good reason and that means
you can't necessarily prove that they're
true
inside of the system i would love to
hear somebody say it that way i've never
heard it
properly done by a logician so it has
too much of a g-whiz thing all right
tyler goldstein is asking eric if i
remember correctly i think you said on a
podcast
the next scientific dynamos may be
religious people
do you think these people would have to
find unorthodox paths presenting their
work outside of academia ish
the problem is that right now we're
having a huge problem with
academics becoming too self-destructive
in a weird way you have you pay a cost
for being religious that you often
believe something without
on faith there are religious scientists
who are able to take their faith and
their science and separate them so that
they do good scientific work
but they use their convictions to
potentially martyr themselves and put
themselves in low probability of success
situations
that's what that was a reference to and
i happen to know some biologists who
don't agree with darwinian theory
but if there were problems in the
neo-darwinian synthesis let's say
you might find that the people like
richard dawkins would be wanting to
say there are no problems in that
synthesis
and you might be dependent on somebody
even assuming there's no god and
everything is completely materialistic
the challenge might have to come from a
religious person who would destroy their
career going up against neo-darwinian
um ideas but then that person might
actually point out you know that thing
you said about random mutations that
can't possibly be the engine
uh of a principal engine of evolution
because the search space doesn't conform
even over long
periods of time with many um bacteria
exploring
uh genetic variants of certain primary
sequences so that kind of
that kind of self-destructive energy
comes from religions one of the reasons
why religions have
been very difficult to get rid of by
atheists because in fact when people
have that kind of faith and conviction
they start thinking beyond themselves
and that that's a very potent force
is there anyone you're afraid to debate
sure
care to name them can you name her what
can you name her
um let me think well look there's one
person who absolutely
terrifies me intellectually and that's
ed whitman
all right we're gonna try to arrange
that as you know that's my white whale
my white wit and whale
um is there any position in physics that
you think is being promoted purely for
hype
in other words wormholes time works the
simulation hypothesis
i mean these are all things that we i
think of as hype what do you think is
the biggest hype
well i i think the whole um
g-wizification of things that are real
like boltzmann brains the multivarks
you know it's like uh we're always
interested in
time travel going you know going
backwards and
and wormholes to parallel universes and
you've got to know when
to quit and how to do science fiction
right i feel like what we've done
is we've taken a small number of topics
with maximum sex appeal
we've sexed them up and we've forgotten
how many gorgeous beautiful ideas
um you know i i've been taught
i'll be honest i i've been talking about
this for a while and then i saw
sean carroll do a series called the
biggest ideas in the universe now sean
and i have sort of a weird
relationship with cordial when we meet
each other but there has been some
tension in it
and i wonder whether he had actually
heard me um
on programs like rogan talking about the
hop vibration and things like that
saying why is it that we're not
extolling all the cool things that we do
why do we keep hitting these same topics
because i think he had hit the
multiverse
the boltzmann brain that kind of stuff
pretty hard
that you know to be generous to sean if
i can
i thought he did a beautiful job over a
very large number of very difficult
topics
some of which i had myself you know been
experimenting with talking about so i
think we need to stimulate some of our
science community
communicators to showing more of what it
is that we actually do because it's so
effing cool that it's crazy that we keep
it locked away while we [ __ ] about
things that are of marginal importance
okay rapid fire questions uh james
thompson
is the universe expanding or are atoms
shrinking yes or no
don't don't love the question should
should my kids go to college
or try to find something outside the
college university system
i think we should try to send our
children to graduate school and skip
college we should try to find lambda
school-like
opportunities to cut down the expense
we should partition the subjects that
are super serious
serious as a heart attack subjects and
get them away from the subjects in which
um a penchant for bullshitting and
fashion uh
tends to take over the subject we do
some incredibly important
difficult things at universities and we
do a lot of things that shouldn't be
done at universities
and it's time to divorce them one from
the other so i think it would probably
be good to start doing away with the
current college model and try to figure
out what's next
do you think that uh trump will leave
office
i do do you think that he has a secret
file on the incoming occupant of the
of the oval office i i don't even care
i think that the key problem my guess is
to what's going on is
the the democratic forces and
establishment forces have oversold
just how little fraud there is and the
republican and trump-like forces have
oversold how much there is
and so the weird part about it is that
people are also
kind of lying about the truth and that's
causing us to get very confused it's
somewhat akin to
the question of did hiv cause aids they
jumped the gun on it but it would
it was also true so if you were using a
jump the gun detector you decided that
that was bs
on the other hand if you used an
underlying thing
you'd say well that wasn't originally
true but it turned out to be true
my guess is is that there was way too
much pressure to put biden in office
but that biden actually did win the
election and that's going to be very
difficult for a lot of the trump
supporters i think he's going to come
back in 2024
well you know as a 78 year old guy i
think he's doing a lot of damage to
himself if trump walks out of the old
oval office dabbling incoherently about
so unfair so unfair without putting up a
serious conspiracy theory i mean at this
point
i want to see a serious conspiracy
theory or concede the election
what is your conspiracy if you have the
data if you have the allegations
i want to know them in terms that i can
i can really understand
and i i understand it might take you
five you we might find out the deep
state through the election five years
from now we don't have five years to
wait
so if you don't have it now yeah if you
don't have it for the courts
you're gonna have to leave officer would
you rather have a nobel prize or be
president for two terms guaranteed i
would definitely not
want to be the president of the united
states do you think it's dangerous if a
jew would become president would that be
a good thing for the world
a bad thing for the world what do you
think i think it depends on the jew
okay um let's see here someone wants to
hear a serenade on the way out we'll
give that in a minute
uh if you had a time capsule that you
knew would last a billion years
like a monolith in 2001 a space odyssey
i may have asked you this but i may not
have
what would you put on that monolith in
that monolith
for some species in the future to
discover when they're ready to discover
it
there's a wall that we're going to visit
in the state university of stoneybrook
uh state university of new york stony
brook where i was born the whole
the whole point is to get that wall
right there's a bunch of stuff on that
wall that shouldn't be on it so we have
to deface the wall to remove the things
that are extraneous we have to improve
the things that aren't in their proper
form
but that wall is an unbelievable mecca
and all you young kids if you want to
know
what that monolith should look like go
to the simon center for physics and
geometry
and take a look at that gorgeous indiana
limestone and the beauty
of what is written into that and make
your assignment for your life that you
will understand
what is carved onto that wall by the
time
would you rather shrink to the size of a
dna molecule
or be able to visit the interior of a
black hole
inside the event horizon i was just
hoping to get some sleep this week
well your tuesday's cancelled okay
uh either okay neither one okay i'm a
mesoscale kind of a guy would you rather
go back in time
500 years or forward in time 500 years a
particular weekend i would like to visit
during my uh
junior year of high school but we don't
get do-overs
all right okay eric uh someone's asking
will you serenade us out with something
mind-blowingly amazing from the world of
geometric unity
underneath that yiddish cup of hair
where you serenade us and the guitar
as you take us out maybe uh shalom
aleichem or something like that
for the evening that's about to approach
[Music]
i don't know what to play that's awesome
thank you so much eric we'll do this
again
maybe we'll make it regular i want to
thank the audience all you super
chatters regular chatters
please subscribe to eric's channel on
itunes no no brian's channel
all right fine if you must if you must
please subscribe we've got great guests
jared thought hopefully we'll come on
cnn yang we have come run vafa next week
and we will uh we will update you all
should look for shelley glashow others
to come eric say a few words that you
can't say
sure people need to understand that
brian is getting some of the best
guests in the world they're not polished
they're not necessarily
professional podcast guests and i think
that it's just really important to
recognize
that if you're used to banter excitement
joking
guitar you're not necessarily going to
get that on this channel
but what i want to say that he can't say
is that he's crushing it with respect
to who he's able to get if you're able
to listen
to sheldon glashaw who paid me a dollar
that he owed me for 27 years
that's right i want to bet with him uh
you know shelley is a was a prince of a
guy to give me the dollar after 27 years
finally conceding the bet
kumaran vapha lenny suspend
noam chomsky i am clearly not qualified
to sweep
the floor of this channel habituate
yourself
if you can to understanding that these
are some of the most important minds
that you're going to listen to
and if they're not polished and if they
don't make sense
i would start to pick up an acquired
taste because uh
the the only podcast that's getting
comparable guests
uh is graham farmela's podcast which is
barely a podcast at all
and uh this is really an honor to get to
appear here
in the company of such incredibly
serious people so um
keep trying to figure out what we're
doing here and we'll figure out serious
scientific podcasts and i want to thank
you for talking me down from the ledge
on many occasions as i get my footing
not true no no no it is you you actually
do
a great deal of good for me for my
family i love you we love you
shabbat shalom everybody out there thank
you so much and uh we'll do this again
and and stay tuned for more
wonderful content as we go into the
impossible signing off your fearful host
brian keating
and his good buddy eric weinstein good
night everyone